et pour en parler nous sommes avec
xavier moreau fondateur de strates paul
bonsoir xavier moreau merci d'être avec
nous le chef de la diplomatie donc
exhortant on vient d'entendre à ce mardi
son homologue russe à une désescalade
immédiate dans le même temps quasiment
le premier ministre paul johnson qui
affirme ce soir qu'il existe un danger
clair et imminent d'intervention
militaire russe en ukraine on a
décidément l'impression de tourner en
boucle
oui je pense qu'on en est encore au
moins jusqu'à la fin du mois de février
où les occidentaux vont nous jouer ce
psychodrame
cela dit je pense que les choses vont
plutôt dans le bon sens d'une part parce
que si vous lisez la presse ukrainienne
et bien en fait les ukrainiens eux ne
veulent absolument plus du tout de cette
crise plusieurs fois le ministre de la
défense le présent c'est nice qui
lui-même a dit qu' il ne fallait pas il
fallait arrêter de me jeter de l'huile
sur le feu donc on est toujours un peu
dans ce paradoxe c'est qu'on a toujours
l'impression entre bling canet lavrov on
avait déjà cette impression quand ils se
sont rencontrés mais on l'appareil après
le coup de téléphone c'est à dire qu'ils
n'ont pas négocié la même chose blinken
parle de l'ukraine sa graine lavrov
parle des garanties de sécurité que la
russie demande à l'otan et parce que
pour les russes la question de l'ukraine
et régler les russes n'ont pas
l'intention dans les halles cren ils en
ont ils n'ont absolument aucun intérêt
est donc la seule question qui se pose
c'est les garanties de sécurité et ces
garanties de sécurité pour l'instant
washington n'est pas prête à les donner
mais les deux camps sont partisans de
continuer les discussions ce qui ce qui
est une bonne chose d'ailleurs vladimir
poutine a conclu sa conférence de presse
avec viktor orban de là dessus en disant
j'espère que ça va que ça va continuer
qu'on va arriver à quelque chose
globalement je pense retenez moi mais
bon temps boris johnson a lui persiste
il dit ils jugent vital que moscou
reculer choisissent la voie de la
diplomatie avertissements qu'une
intervention militaire donc serait un
désastre pour la russie et le monde on a
le sentiment que c'est voilà qui conte
pour être familier on est deux à danser
le tango là c'est pas vraiment le cas
ben johnson dans son contenu ou tout
seul ben oui vous avez tout à fait
raison de le dire parce qu'il est tout
seul boris johnson le l'angleterre de
boris johnson n'est pas le sait du 19e
siècle elle ne domine pas le monde et tu
le sais très bien qu'il ait pris
l'initiative d'aller à kiev dans le même
moment il ya son ministre de la défense
qui vient d'arriver à moscou pour
rencontrer sergueï choïgou le ministre
de la défense russe donc on va voir ce
que ça va donner mais je pense surtout
que
johnson en fait des tonnes parce que
justement aujourd'hui il n'y a plus
grand chose derrière lui la personne qui
compte aujourd'hui c'est enfin le l'état
qui compte la nation qui compte pour la
russie c'est ce sont les états unis
s'est absolument pas l'angleterre qui
est je dirais un joueur de second ordre
dans cette histoire alors faut-il lui
effectivement vous l'avez dit a dit
espérer trouver une solution tout en
accusant d'ailleurs washington
d'utiliser l'ukraine comme un instrument
pour entraîner un conflit armé votre
analyse oui je pense que je pense que il
a raison c'est à dire que l'idée en fait
non pas forcément de tout de tout
l'homme à dire l'état l'état américain
moi je pense que byden aimerait bien
régler le problème avec la russie pour
pouvoir passer à autre chose et
s'occuper de la chine mais je pense
qu'il y encore toute une partie de
l'establishment américain notamment sans
doute les services secrets partie du
pentagone qui eux aimeraient bien aller
jusqu'au bout et pour ça en fait c'est
provoquer une intervention russe dans le
donbass en organisant une opération
militaire est d'ailleurs il ya on
observe du côté ukrainien une
accumulation de matériel d'une
accumulation
de personnel moi je pense que ça n'ira
pas jusque là parce que céline ce qui
n'a pas reçu le feu vert de joe biden
pour le faire je pense conclut céline ce
qui lui-même a compris que son économie
ne peut plus se permettre cette
situation ils ont déjà perdu
officiellement 13 5 milliards de dollars
à cause de cette situation deux de
tension et de toute manière l'armée
chrétienne n'est même pas certaine de
l'emporter contre les les armes et des
républiques de donetsk est lougansk tout
seul c'est à dire que elle peut perdre
la guerre avant même que la russie
interviennent et les armes qui ont été
donnés d'ailleurs on en a souvent parlé
ce sont des armes antichars de courte
portée ce sont 6 bayraktar donc ces
fameux drones mais y en a six donc ça ne
changera pas le rapport de forces sur le
front donc effectivement devient poutine
a raison qu'une partie de
l'establishment eux mêmes non seulement
américaines et occidentales aimerait
pousser la russie à intervenir pour
mettre une vague de sanctions s'ils
tentaient qu'ils osent mettre ces
sanctions il ya plus grand chose à
mettre comme sanction et la russie est
largement capable de tenir face à une
telle menace d'autant plus qu'elle va
recevoir non seulement soutien de la
chine mais du brésil le vice-président
brésilien vient de déclarer que la
russie était légitime à vouloir garantir
sa sécurité à ses frontières c'est sûr
vous aviez moreau avec poutine qui a
jugé clair que les états unis et l'otan
avaient choisi jusqu'ici d'ignorer les
préoccupations russes on regarde de sa
sécurité aujourd'hui auxquels peuvent
être justement les options que peut
prendre que peuvent prendre la russie
la première option c'est de continuer
les négociations ce sur quoi washington
et moscou sont d'accord et dans le pire
des cas et bien c'est de rejouer la
crise des missiles de cuba c'est à dire
que ça a été évoqué je crois par le vice
ministre des affaires étrangères russe
qui a dix qui ne s'interdisait pas
pourquoi pas d'aller mettre des missiles
à cuba au venezuela et puis et puis ça
finira comme la crise de cuba c'est à
dire que les rues se retireront leurs
missiles de cuba en échange qui à
l'époque les les américains avaient
retiré leurs missiles de turquie leurs
missiles le jupiter donc je pense qu'on
va un peu dans une situation comme ça je
pense aussi qu'il ya quelque chose se
prépare avec la chine on verra
rapidement dans quelques jours avec
l'ouverture des jeux olympiques est la
rencontre entre 6 jingping lanières
poutine mais je pense que c'est tout cet
empressement de la russie a demandé dès
des garanties écrites je pense que c'est
aussi pour préparer quelque chose de
manière formelle avec la chine petit
détour juriste à la base donc ils aiment
bien que les choses soient à se reposer
sur le papier ils ne croient plus aux
promesses et il a bien raison entre
d'entre nous merci beaucoup monsieur
moreau d'avoir été avec nous et nous
avoir apporté votre analyse